[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author is my co-host today as we talk
about your life your relationships your
money your career whatever your question
is we are here to help we are excited
today it is yet another book launch day
here at ramsey we've said that a lot
lately this is the fourth book we've
launched in about six months and uh the
fourth best seller however this one's
really really special as if they're not
all special every time you have a new
kid is special and this one right here
is absolutely fabulous dr john deloney's
new book own your past
change your future a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness coming off of the material
of him having two phds one in counseling
one in higher ed the dr john deloney
show and this whole idea that our
stories
and the traumas that our body has stored
can be changed that's right
we've entered this weird
nexus in the world man where we've got
all the answers all the technology all
of the stuff
and we are more anxious and depressed
and burned out and cooked and angry and
rattled than ever ever
and man
there's so much out there so much great
stuff out there
but it's so much and even i've been
living in this stuff for 20 years it
just bogs me down and so this book was
my attempt to
bring it all together what can a regular
person like me and my wife and my kids
what could what are some things we can
do to change our life
you know heal and move to heal from
the broken places different people have
different kinds of broken places
different causes for the broken places
different depths of brokenness
on different issues everybody's got
something
everybody's got a story or 73 a bunch of
them right 73 stories and
that's kind of the way you framed the
book up uh when i was reading through
the manuscript when we originally were
looking at the
uh you know putting the thing together
and working through the edit process and
everything uh i love stories
uh but i had never thought about how
they
uh they leave a grain they leave a a
groove in our brain yep and we will
track that thing down so one of the
stories in the book is
my sister is a savant she is smarter
than me 10x and my little brother missed
one or two questions on the act and that
was it and then there was me in the
middle and i could run fast that was
kind of my thing
i got asked to
try out for or to take some tests for
the the
gifted and talented when i was in third
grade third grade dave this never
happened to me john i know i know i know
this is a futuristic thing not an
integrate john
but i took the test of course i was my i
had a smart little brother my sister was
smart
i didn't get in
and then you fast forward to oh that'll
be okay and what about this and you need
to be in these classes instead of these
dave i'm two phds in and if i'm not if i
get tired
or i've eaten just enough gummy bears
i'll start thinking i wonder if i should
get
another thing i'm still chasing
that there's a third grade test from a
third grader and so when i can stop and
go what am i do why am i chasing that
story down and we have stories like that
from that thing the girlfriend said the
way our uncle treated us what that coach
said to us one time that dress makes you
look fat that dr yes that dre you don't
pretty girls don't eat that kind of food
boys only do this no one you're not
allowed to be sad all these stories that
have just cast this vision for us and we
live them out over and over and over and
that turns into generational trauma on
top of generational trauma and at some
point as the great terry reel says you
gotta turn and stare down the forest
fire and say enough i'm gonna be the one
you've done it i'm trying to we're all
trying to do that for our kids and for
future generations and this book is the
blueprint on how to do that i want to
change my family tree that's right we
talk about it in the financial realm
right all the time and everyone kind of
has that dream to change their family
tree to go you know i'm never going to
do that with my kids and then you open
your mouth and you're you hear it man
you you hear the parent voice that's the
word the exact same verbiage right with
the exact same tonality
an accent even it's all i mean it's like
how did he just like wow that just
happened it's lodged way in there man
yeah and so yeah you but there is a way
to get better that's right there is a
way to improve and we all but my point
is we all have kids when we say we're
not going to do that which means we have
the desire to get better that's right we
have the desire to change our story
to uh uh you know to change
and those of us that are believers this
is not a book exclusively for christians
but uh it's a book for anyone including
christians and uh by a christian yeah
and so it it but those of us that are
believers we believe that you can change
that you can be transformed that's the
cornerstone right you can be and people
who aren't believers believe you can be
transformed or change too we just think
there's a higher source god
that i can do all things through christ
who strengthens me and i can be
transformed by the renewing of my mind
and i can start quoting scriptures over
the top of this and i can change my kids
by speaking right blessings
over them
and not in some weird mystic way but
just in other words be nice to your kids
act differently right
you don't have to make this some kind of
spiritual thing it's be nice well and
most of us are
we we act with the models we've been
given
we treat our kids the way our dads
treated us and then the way they treated
theirs and what's so amazing about your
show is something as simple as a
debt-free scream
gives somebody driving their car all by
themselves
a picture of oh that's me and they did
it i can do it and this book is that for
how to treat your kids how to treat your
spouse how to treat your co-workers how
to take care of your neighborhood and
your community how to take care of
yourself man
how many of us dave talk to ourselves in
a way that we would never
let somebody talk to the waitress or
talk to the woman at the cash register
everyone else every one of us yeah
self-talk is one of the meanest human
beings out there right and so just
you're talking about being kind this
book's gonna help you learn how to be
kind to yourself and the healing will
start there man i'm excited brand new
it's launch day which means uh the
pre-sales started today the actual uh
street date will be in april april 19 i
believe uh yes i recall it and uh the
book the brand new book own your past
change your future it is on sale
available for pre-order today
if you go to ramseysolutions.com
we're going to throw in all kinds of
extras about 300 worth of bonus items
that includes the ebook includes the
audiobook and something we've never done
before we teamed up with one of your
sponsors the folks at betterhelp which
is online counseling and we're going to
give you a 300 value a one year or one
month
ticket
for free counseling yeah online i that
company stepped up in a major way
they're big believers in this book but
the idea that i can get through this and
go whoa i need to make a call right now
and they said we'll step up and provide
you that number right and of course it
helps them but a month free counseling
with uh with the pre-sale order it's
only 20 bucks so if you wanted to do
this wrong you could say i got a month
counseling for 20 bucks and they give me
a book i'll send you a book that's not
exactly the way we're doing it but it is
it's it's the net result it's a great
yeah i'm really grateful to them for
stepping up yeah that's pretty cool and
that's with the folks at betterhelp so
the book is
own your past
own it
change your future dr john deloney
brand new major trade
book this thing's going to be huge
the content is
world changing life changing be sure you
get it pre-ordered right now at
ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host
launch day on the pre-sale of his new
book own your past
change your future tyler is going to
start off this hour in manchester new
hampshire hi tyler welcome to the ramsey
show
hey thanks for taking my call today sure
man what's up
well here's the situation he bought a
house in denver colorado back in may of
2013 for 300 283 thousand dollars
and current balance remaining is about
220k
and when we moved our original plan was
to keep it as an airbnb short-term
rental denver changed its laws where you
can't have it be a short-term resident a
rental if it's not your primary
residence because now we live in new
hampshire so we're currently
transitioned to the corporate rental
scene which is 30 days or more and it's
very successful rented out probably 98
of the time where
yearly we probably we gross 80 000 we
net 20k
at the after the paying the mortgage
paying all the bills my question to you
is should we sell
today because our we're fought right now
we fall in a two out of five
five year rule for primary residents we
did live there for two consecutive years
so our current mortgage in new hampshire
is at three hundred and thirty thousand
dollars
and i think i gave you all the
information that i was going to tell you
you did how old are you
i am 37
okay
um
as you know probably from if you've
listened to the show for 30 seconds the
way we try to answer questions here is
if i woke up in your shoes knowing what
i know having done all the stupid bad
things i have done in my life
what would i do if i woke up in your
situation
okay
a couple of observations
number one
this thing takes up a lot of your energy
your time and your emotions
for 20 grand
number two
it is across the united states on the
other side of the world
number three you were not living in new
hampshire and said to yourself
i want to go buy
a corporate rental in denver
you became a corporate rental landlord
by default not by strategy or design not
by intentionality agreed
agreed
um
is there a number four there probably is
um
all that to say
as much as i love real estate and as
much as you have maximized this property
oh number four would be the capital
gains issue
um
you're going to have a gain of how much
on this
i would say the tax accounts are random
numbers for me if we were to sell
before the capital gains we just had to
pay depreciation that'd be 5k and if we
sold
after may of 2022
we would owe 55 000. yeah yeah so you
got this
up to a half million dollars of gain
is tax free on your personal residence
if you have uh haven't violated the two
and five rule which is what you're
talking about
so um and and that as of may is when you
have violated that you've rented it more
than three of the last five right
so um
at that point yeah so what would you get
for the house if you sold it right now
what's it worth now
between six hundred thousand and six
hundred fifty thousand so pay off your
home
mortgage correct yeah that's number five
i listed five reasons why i listed five
reasons just now why i would sell it i
don't have a good reason to keep it
okay i have one additional fact here i
do have about three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in stock options from a
company i worked for
which is also an option to sell because
i'm
not very diversified in that it's just
one company's stock so it's curious
would if you had that those facts would
you sell the stock just to pay off your
primary residence to keep your
rental i'd sell the stock i would sell
the stock to get more diversified and i
would sell the rental house i'd sell
them both that's right and then if you
want to buy and do some kind of a rental
let's do it in your neighborhood there
okay and if you want to fool with the
type of rental you've been fooling with
if you're enamored with the airbnb or
the corporate rental scene but as you
described i mean you're bringing in 80
and netting 20
um which you know after mortgage and
everything so um
there's just not a lot of fun here a lot
of fun for me is bringing in 80 and most
of it stays that's right that's more fun
um on you know three six hundred
thousand dollars you're making a twenty
thousand dollar rate of return or fund
is selling this house and having no
house payment in 45 days
that's real good yeah and or having the
money from the stock sale to buy another
rental you know pay one for your next
neighbors closer to you and pay cash for
it i like that so um i'm
uh if i'm you i'm out of the property in
denver but those are my five reasons
and i just have to think through kind of
a pros list a cons list the old thing
you draw a line down the middle of the
page and i start looking at it and
thinking that through and uh generally
that list serves me pretty well
different items on the list have
different weights sure you know you
could have one item on there that
offsets the other 14 on the other side
like i just like it shut up you know
that kind of thing that's okay that's an
okay item to have on there but there's a
lot of reasons to be out of this and i
think you already knew that you just
wanted me to say it out loud teach me
about the two and five rule uh if you
own a your personal residence and you
move out and start renting it okay and
you rent it more than three of the last
five years okay
over two years
then you lose your capital gains
exemption on your personal residence you
sell your personal residence you can
make up to a half million dollars profit
married filing jointly no taxes so i
thought when you sold it and if he sells
it as a rental after that he's rented it
for too long he loses that so he'd have
55 000 in extra taxes if he waits till
may if you sell your primary residence
yeah zero taxes up to a half million
dollars gain oh i thought you had to
roll it into your next house that's an
old rule from the 70s oh wow okay well
that rule's been gone for
almost 20 years now okay fantastic yeah
you flat out make 250 000 single 500 000
married profit
don't have to touch it wow okay you can
do anything you want to do with it yeah
i'd get up today yeah there you go and
and you don't have to roll it into
another property you don't have to do a
1031 you have to do anything we're not
that's because it's still classified as
a personal residence until you rent it
too long
out of the five years and then you lose
your that exemption you know it's no
longer treated as personal residence now
it's treated as selling a rental
property so you got taxes on all the
games there you go that's how that works
josh is with us josh is in charlotte
north carolina hey josh what's up
hi guys good to talk to you
um i'm a former antioch kid so it's
great to talk to you dave oh cool
so i wanted to ask you guys me and my
wife are in baby step 3b we just
finished paying off our emergency fund
and we've got a small project that we
got to do
before we can start investing
my main question for you is before i got
into the baby steps uh i saw a video of
yours years ago um talking about
car payments and how you shouldn't you
know spend so much money paying a car
instead you should pay yourself that car
payment so that you can pay cash for
cars for life um
my question is i was wondering if this
principle uh still applies in the baby
steps or if it may have been an outdated
uh type of thing and the reason i'm
asking is because if we applied that
principle
that'd be about 400
a month that me and my wife are putting
towards our next cars um and it's not a
lot we didn't have big car payments but
the problem is is we don't have a huge
income so uh if we continue to do that
once we start our investing
we're going to have a hard time hitting
that 15 mark yeah john doing that the
answer is the answer is very simple okay
i
love that video it's a free car video
it's called and um
the the but but i did a poor job of
communicating in the video i communicate
all the math nerd stuff fabulously
because it's one of my gifts but but
what i didn't communicate was that it's
not a principle by which we tell you to
actually go do things i was merely
trying and i goofed to illustrate the
idea that if you will save and invest
money rather than pay payments
you will end up wealthy and the point
being that if you took the the the
illustration of that point was that if
you invest a car payment instead of
paying a car payment pretty soon the
money off the investments alone will buy
you a car ever so often but the concept
is not should not be trapped within the
subject of car the concept is generally
stay out of debt invest and then you've
got money
but the concept is also don't borrow
money for cars don't borrow money for
anything right because if you got
payments instead of paying yourself
payments
you can
you know you don't become wealthy when
you pay yourself payments you become
wealthy so
it's not outdated the the illustration
is still fabulous i'm still proud i did
it but i didn't do a good job of saying
this is what this means is not you
should actually do it what it means is
that you should actually save rather
than be in debt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage jason and lindsay are
with us hey guys how are you great how
are you welcome welcome where do you
guys live oklahoma city oh i love
oklahoma city thanks for being with us
thank you all the way over here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off 105 000.
how long did that take 22 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time about 95 000 wow very good
what do you guys do for a living
i work very hard at home uh
homeschooling take your kids
okay and then i manage uh property for
our church okay excellent very good so
what kind of debt was your 105 000
our mortgage
way to go you guys thank you excellent
excellent excellent so man oh man you
paid off your house and everything so
tell us the story what happened 22
months ago
it was actually way before that in high
school we dated in high school and
my parents for his graduation gave him
your financial piece revisited book wow
and he would say
he never read anything that wasn't
required at school so that was really
like his first
just for enjoyment voluntary voluntary
readiness your future in-laws give you a
book that's required reading yeah yeah
and he was just
he read it right away and totally bought
into everything and my dad was a new
listener on your show
and he bought us tickets to go to one of
your live events and
i'm not sure if i've told them this i
probably have but at the time i was
probably 16 and
did wasn't great at math and didn't care
about money really so far at that point
so i expected it to not be fun and it
was so fun and it was so engaging and
um we just
loved it and we decided from the moment
we were married that's what we wanted to
do we we've never had any debt since
we've been married except a mortgage so
it's been a dream this whole time
to pay it off and
so so we had a goal that we wanted to
have it paid off by the time we were 30.
and we were working towards that and had
made significant progress and then god
told us uh hey i've got some kids that
don't have a home and we need you to
take them and make a home for them and
so we had to change plans and use all of
our house money
to buy beds and cars and things like
that and so um we had a little bit of a
delay but here but here we are so how
many kids did you adopt in that one
swath uh so we have six that we adopted
within a total of about less than two
years we adopted six and one officer was
there a group there was
um three siblings and three siblings oh
okay wow all right so that first group
was the
kind of god whispering in your ear or
yelling in your face or whatever he did
yeah okay these kids need a mom and dad
and you're it yeah okay that's so cool
you guys yeah so you got a three and
three grouping total of six what age
what's the age range
um well 15 and then we actually just had
a baby six months ago so
oh wow
okay why not yeah well that was that was
in the middle of our so in january um of
20 we just decided you know what we
we're done bringing babies home and we
aren't moving anymore we really want to
get serious about this because we had
other mortgages that we had tried to
tackle but we had moved for different
reasons
and in the middle of working really hard
to pay this off he was surprised baby um
and so that was kind of one of our
moments of
um what do we do we're working on paying
off our mortgage how are we going to
have a baby also and and we did god
we just kept working and got through it
all you've never had any debt ever
except your mortgage correct
that's incredible that's why they're
smiling so big right that's how you can
have seven kids and be that joyous right
we are so happy to be here how big are
you how big how long you all been
married
15 years yep oh wow okay
so you're what 35 i'm 35 and 37. okay
all right wow
so this story this story goes on a long
time that's exactly right
yep six kids then a kid and a paid four
house in 15 years pretty stinking
amazing that's exactly right all
straight out of high school high school
sweethearts yep yeah and so the season
10 would be 12 so
so this is like 2006 or something you
went to that event in oklahoma city yeah
we got married in 2006. we had went to
one while we were dating before that oh
my god it might have been 2000 2003 is
when he graduated and read your book
almost 20 years ago yeah we actually saw
russ carroll too yeah
oh my goodness russ was our first team
member served at some live events that
was fun yeah
so what was the hardest part over the
last two years and i feel silly asking
uh mother and father of seven during a
pandemic what was the hardest part of
the last couple years to get this thing
moving keep it going uh i would say
saying no to them uh because there's a
lot of things to say no to and he says
saying no to me
so so that you can say no to them yeah
right yeah we just have to you just have
to say no to a lot of things and
now you can say yes yes now we can say
yes forever yeah have you received that
first paycheck
deposited but you didn't have a mortgage
payment oh yes how does that feel
it feels amazing it's all your money
it's all our money we don't owe anybody
anything
wow wow it's a beautiful home yeah the
home they just showed it on youtube wow
that's powerful this is so cool you guys
so um so the idea that you can't do this
biblical financial thing and stay out of
debt and get out of debt and live on a
plan with a big family is hogwash
they're proving that it can be you can't
do it if in adopt too oh and adopt yeah
adoption is let's just try time six
right
totally false you you can you can do
anything you set your mind to and that
you're a team on yeah you just have to
have a goal has to be in front of you
stick to your plan we had a i know
there's a picture of our youngest
daughter she's color in a box we made a
chart really for
them to feel part of the team and for us
to see it every day and i told him it
was just as motivating for me and they
colored boxes off every month for
however many payments we made that month
and
um
so yeah so you tell people having a plan
is a big deal what else do you tell them
the key to getting your house paid off
with seven kids at 35 is
um again it would be saying no to a lot
of things and being a team if you have a
family if you have kids and make your
kids part of it because they i know
you're going to ask biggest cheerleaders
but they truly are and they love filling
a part of it and
um it was all of our dream together
started out as ours and became all of
ours yeah
i would say sticking to the budget
budget and uh just yeah having a goal
and having it in front of you every day
that you see yeah you guys seem so uh
mature beyond your years so chill what
was the biggest fight you had about
money during this time
um
it had to be one yeah
i can't really remember i don't think
they fight dude i don't i don't i don't
care
they were middle schoolers i think they
would sometimes they've been in love
since they were four yeah it already
sees it coming and it's like the matrix
you already know how to get out of the
way yeah
it's incredible
i think now
i wouldn't call it a fight but i enjoy
being able to say
no i can buy that now we don't have a
mortgage
you lost your leverage now i know i know
we need a new goal we need a new goal to
always be when we pay off the mortgage
then we can get that so now i remind him
we've paid it off well i love played
well played i love that god can whisper
to you
and you have the courage to be obedient
and still get your goals and still give
these kids a home you guys are pretty
amazing people that you really are they
are they are some lucky kiddos without a
doubt and uh lucky that mom and dad more
than anything else can hear god's voice
and obey
because that makes for a great life
makes for an incredible time i'm so
proud of y'all thank you look at that
get them all up in this
shot everybody wants to meet them and
everything is good
there's a lot of family trees here
absolutely we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaire for you because that's
the next step in your process the next
chapter in your story and you will be
there without a doubt and uh wow i think
you're already wealthy beyond measure oh
my goodness this is pretty pretty
amazing
pretty cool and i copy a total money
makeover maybe you can give it to
somebody and it'll be the first book
they read that's not mandatory you know
i love those stories i love those
stories so uh well done thank you all
right it's jason and lindsay and the
tribe of seven yeah i love it all right
105 000 paid off in 22 months making 95
house and everything by the time they're
35. count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two
one
[Applause]
oh man
that is so fabulous wow what a great
story powerful this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five jeff is with us jeff is in
los angeles hi jeff how are you
well i'm just great i thank you so much
for having me on sure what's
up well uh i came to you on my evening
commutes uh you come on after hannity
and that's how i came to you and i
listened to that i really like what i
hear on your show thank you
you're welcome thank you so
i'm 59
never owned my primary residence
coming to retirement and planning on
purchasing
a retirement home
but i'm
completely un
experienced in the real estate world
and i want to
treat myself well but not not
come anywhere close to
getting into
becoming house poor
so i wanted your advice on on
what to spend
and then also
how to pay for it
okay
how much money do you have
2.5 million okay what are you thinking
about spending on a house
thinking 500 okay
if you pay cash for that there'd be no
problem
okay now just use some of your
2.2.5 million and whatever the
millionaires that we have studied
their homes from a one to five million
dollar net worth we studied about 10 000
of them in the research that we've done
the data tells us that the typical
millionaire
in that setting in the one to five
million uh net worth which is where you
said their home is somewhere around one
quarter to one third
of their net worth
okay a quarter two so you're you're
right there i mean you know you're
you're exactly there
in that range with a half million if you
told me a million i'd start to flinch
because i'd be like 50 almost of your
net worth or 45 of your net worth i'd
flinch and i'd start asking more
questions i'm not taking out a mortgage
you've got the money
um
and a half a million unless you're
moving out of la is not much of a
property
well i am moving out of the lane okay
all right where are you moving yeah
uh back to
uh arizona back to the uh i grew up in
scottsdale i would like to go back to
scottsdale um yeah you can you can get a
decent property there for a half million
okay that's cool i mean depending on the
neighborhood you're in all that kind of
junk right as always but i mean that's
that's a doable uh
task what did you do for a living
where'd all this money come from
uh i'm i do lighting for films
so you're just working doing that all
these years you own a company or
officially yes but it's just me
the company is literally just me but but
you do have to i do have to have a
license but i mean so you're you're um
you're an independent subcontractor in
the film world
essentially
and you've saved your money all these
years or did you make it all in one lick
no no it's just been a slow slow go the
whole way i i've
yeah just save save and keep how much of
it did you inherit
memory wise it's been a little while i
think 180 from my dad
and
the rest of it that's it okay all right
so you're you don't have this wealth
because of an inherited money you have
it because you've systematically saved
it over a large number of years which
again you
you fit the model of the typical
millionaire that we studied i'm going to
send you a copy of the book baby steps
millionaires because you are one you
didn't follow our baby steps to get
there but you are a a typical
millionaire in america today how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can do you'll enjoy the
book because you'll go oh that's me i'm
in there
and on behalf of not so pretty faces in
the world thank you for being a great
lighting guy over the years man
dave you and i both man those lighting
no it's the makeup people that have
bondo that i need
the filler those lighting folks man
that's a hard job they're up on
scaffolding all the time and hanging and
it's working all kind of stuff it's
incredible work man appreciate you you
worked hard for that he's done a great
job too yeah you're right on track
brother i wouldn't worry about your plan
at all it sounds very reasonable
washington dc michael's on the line hey
michael what's up
hey guys thanks for having me on i
appreciate it sure how can we help
hey uh so my wife and i are 65 000 in
debt right now uh mostly credit cards
and some from a car um and
right now when we've looked at our
budget we put it on a an excel sheet and
at the end of the day we have more going
uh in the negative than coming in uh
positive to spend
on our daily needs
okay and we we we're we're kind of at a
loss right now we're
financially we're scared for our future
of uh you know what we're supposed to do
and we're so much in the negative that
we can't even get to the positive i
can't even okay i'm trying to follow
your baby steps of saving up a thousand
dollars and
i can't even do that because i'm in the
negative every month
what do y'all do for a living
i'm a teacher and my wife works for the
government
okay what do you teach
elementary school okay good okay
um
and so what's your household income
uh about a hundred time a year okay
how much do you owe on the car
uh i owe 17 000.
okay
well i hear the stress in your voice and
i have been there uh you make good money
you live in an expensive area so 110
doesn't go that far it sounds like you
ought to be able to live on that but
you're in washington dc it's expensive
um how much is your house payment or
rent
uh it's about two thousand a month
okay
that's high but it's not what's killing
it so where's the rest of money go yeah
your money's there's a leak somewhere
how much do you all eat out all the time
well credit cards are what are you
buying with the credit cards
it's from past credit card usage
you only have forty thousand dollars in
credit card debt
yeah
it's the payments are
between the each of them
for about 200 300 a month
yeah
okay
okay um
here's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes it sounds like there is uh
you are being killed death by a thousand
cuts i don't hear a major
hole in the side of the boat i hear lots
of little leaks
from years of doing budgets with people
that's what i hear
okay
um so the little leaks sound like this
you're gonna go on a scorched earth
thing and turn this thing around because
you're stuck the good news is you're
sick and tired of being stuck i can hear
it in your voice you're a little bit
scared a little bit desperate a little
bit pissed off that's a really good mix
for changing things because you're going
to have to get radical so here's what
i'm going to do
i'm going to start a tutoring business
tomorrow you can make 50 to 100 an hour
tutoring elementary school kids in the
afternoons i've had people get out of
debt doing tutoring that were teachers
all the time i hear it all the time and
there's such a need of people like you
to be able to do this and
then you're not going to see the inside
of a restaurant unless you're working
there you guys eat out too much you
spend too freaking much money outside
the walls of your home
you don't need to go on vacation period
until you get this mess cleaned up you
need to get the credit cards out tonight
light a candle and have a plastic
surgery ceremony and chop them all up
into little bitty stinking pieces and
you are never borrowing money again for
anything in it with the extra income and
the reduced outgo if you can have you
gotten a big tax refund
no okay if you can't find some money in
dialing this thing down with all of that
you're going to sell the car but the car
is not your problem it just might be a
little bit of the solution a 17 000 car
debt on 110 000 income is not good but
it's not drowning you and i'm talking to
a guy who sounds like he's drowning
that's right
what is this split me your your salaries
what do you make versus your wife
uh my wife is about 60 hour about 15.
okay
there is a hard moment and nobody likes
to talk about this there is a hard
moment when you look at your total life
you're teaching government work and you
look at how y'all are scraping by you're
scratching your claw and you ask
yourselves is this where we have to live
is this where we want to live is there
another place that we would be
interested in doing life and my wife and
i have had that conversation it's hard
it's gut-wrenching
and it also was life-giving ultimately
right so some of those big existential
questions you can have on top of the
grinding and the clawing that you're
doing to get out of this thing to get
unstuck
so hang on kelly's going to pick up and
i'm going to sign you up for financial
peace university in every dollar the
premium map and we will show you
hand and glove how to do exactly what
you need to do to get this mess
straightened up we'll walk with you
brother hold on
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
send clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john deloney ramsey
personality best-selling author host of
the dr john dolone show is my co-host
today and today is the day that the new
book goes on pre-sale his brand new book
own your past
change your future a not so complicated
approach to relationships
mental health and wellness on sale today
pre-ordered and guess what there is a uh
well there's a record-setting number of
them already going out the first day
congratulations john thanks man i'm
excited it's a pretty incredible book
and i i predict it'll be yet another
best seller and um
uh it's quite a process to write your
first one oh i tell you what especially
when you come out of academia and for
writing for not for academics writing
for real people is different well the
number of people who said uh i don't
know what you're talking about can you
say that again and then i would say it
again say it again say it again so the
refinement process has been great
it's a pain in the butt it's what it
editing is refinement process is great
is latin for yeah it pretty much sucks
pretty much pretty much
the editing process where they
you you have a baby and then someone
says your baby ugly that baby's ugly let
me dress it up you think no i don't wear
those clothes yeah and they say well
nobody knows what you're talking about
oh it's a harsh it's just harsh
there's a world class content and
creative people where your work is
criticized every day i don't know how
you do it dave you know what's worse the
i mean
your words are hard and you feel really
important you think the words you wrote
are really important and then somebody
comes and says i don't know that's hard
when somebody looks at 35 pictures of
your face and says man
we gotta shoot that looks really great
but your face and you're like yeah
that's all i got man it's all i got to
work with you can't edit that i can't
change that yeah no it's a great cover
it is a good-looking book so good man
good-looking man on a good-looking book
smart guy we're ready to rock and roll
excited about this own your past change
your future it's about changing your
story that's exactly right man i'm sick
of everybody having all the answers and
all the technology and all this stuff
and i'm watching people and myself and
my friends and family included melting
and enough's enough this is a book about
mental health relationships that anybody
can understand and it's for all of us to
get our hearts back our homes back let's
get this country back man let's just
start healing people i'm ready
i'm ready own your past change your
future on sale now ramsay solutions dot
com you get 200 worth of pre-sale items
when you pre-purchase pretty incredible
comes with a free month of counseling
yeah i mean that's that's pretty cool
over the top
over the top all right let's go to katie
in colorado springs to kick off this
hour hi katie how are you
hi gabe doing well how are you great how
can we help
well um we're dating step 7
and my son who's 17 just about 18 now
has been racing go-karts for a couple of
years and
he's ready to move up from basically
from a state level to
more of a regional level basically west
of the mississippi and i'm having a
little trouble deciding what's a
reasonable amount
to
budget for that
okay
so um
where does this lead
when he's done
ultimately i think i don't know any 57
year old go-kart racers
yeah um i mean he understands that when
he's
done with college you know out doing his
own thing that it's going to be
something that if he wants to continue
with that he will have to fund it
himself
does he win prize money
or is this just
are you just supporting a hobby trophy
yeah it's pretty much a hobby uh he took
a
championship in the state league last
year
so he's
basically he's what are you doing i
don't know how this works do you move up
from this to be to driving nascar
uh no just recording um
well the gun cards
there are adult leagues um oh no i know
that but i'm just saying that yeah okay
cause some hobbies actually lead into
stuff i'll give an example okay my my
son played ice hockey i played ice
hockey and i coached my son playing ice
hockey and we had the opportunity to
spend a bazillion dollars to put him on
the travel team however we knew that him
having my dna meant he was not going to
be in the nhl okay
and so this is not going anywhere except
it is recreational sports for fun
and so how much you of course think he's
going to be an f1 driver someday but no
he's it's
it's a hobby uh he is very very good at
it but i i don't see him ever going into
something
that's part of what goes into the
equation is are we going somewhere with
this
that becomes a career i mean if you've
got a kid that's going to be in the nhl
and you want to spend a billion dollars
on travel team and individual coaching
and everything else that's a different
thing than kid playing rec league right
we were playing rec league and you know
we just needed to admit that and budget
accordingly so that's what i was asking
about is that kind of a thing and then
the other thing i guess is as a
percentage of your world or of your net
worth what's your net worth
uh net worth we're probably just under a
million okay and what are we spending on
this hobby
this year to do all of the races that my
husband would like him to be doing uh
we're looking at thirty to forty
thousand dollars that's the magic
our income is about 165.
yeah so that that man i was
you you threw me an underhand softball
pitch here so i've seen this with
baseball kids and i was a baseball kid
that turns into rec league turns into
travel team turns into for a half a
million dollars like dave was talking
about but what i often find
is kids like playing with other kids
it's the moms and the dads who have some
sort of identity investment in this
so when you say and that's a big part of
it yeah i think my husband is living
vicariously through our stuff there you
go
there you go and so there's something
beneath your question here are you
looking for two guys to give you
permission to put the brakes on
something that's out of control
yeah no pun intended horrible honestly i
i think i'm more looking for permission
to to let it happen i mean
where
you know dave always talks about the
security gland um
i grew up
very lower middle class and i am a
hoarder i when i get cash in the savings
account i don't like to let go of it
and um i guess
okay so here's the thing maybe kind of
talk myself
financially this is not going to
bankrupt you you're going to be fine
this is not killing you okay it's not
it's not i'm not aghast at what you're
spending 40 grand based on your income
and based on the fact you have a million
dollars okay okay and your baby steps
seven they're 100 out of debt house and
everything okay and um
i i but what does bother me is
motivation and i don't hear
uh
good motivation down under here and i
think that might also be disturbing you
and you're trying to blame yourself
being cheap
on your disturbance and maybe it's not
maybe it's not you're being cheap maybe
you see that there's
this is not going
it's it's out of it's gotten it was a
fun thing that got out of control right
again and then and dad got some
self-esteem out of it yeah and i'm
wondering if mom feels like she's my dad
trying to protect how much my husband
wants him to race this year that's right
yeah that's a that's a telling line
right there
so financially you're probably okay i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna give you
permission to
stop everything based on just the money
in your situation you probably have the
money but there's other stuff going on
here and the money's talking to you you
need to listen to it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two
five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money hey i wanna circle back
for a second because kids activities
john
is um
one of the things that is a budget
buster in our world
and um
sometimes i get um
roundly and wrongly criticized by saying
no children should ever have any
activity dave ramsey's too cheap you
should never if you're following dave
ramsey plan you should never have a
child in any kind of extracurricular
activity that costs money ever under any
circumstances that's just not true i do
not say that i've never said that ever
in 30 years of doing this
what i have attempted to do is what we
do in the ramsey household is to use
some common sense
when it comes to
kids activities
if a little league baseball is funded
but the college fund isn't
ding ding
wrong right well he might play college
on a scholarship he might not too
she might not too
um statistically speaking probably won't
vary statistically speaking um and and
if they go to college the chances that
they play pro
are one percent
of the ncaa athletes go pro
one
freaking percent so how do we translate
that statistics probably not your kid
not not your kid probably not your kids
not your kid right so um you know let's
think this through then what are
extracurricular activities for
our piano lessons dance lessons
um
a little league sports of all kinds uh
cheerleading
competitions and lessons
uh nothing evil inherently about any of
them but like so many things when they
go to an extreme and they violate common
sense
many times it's more about the adults
than the kids and you bust your budget
doing it yeah i mean i've got a whole
section in this new book about that
about
over the last 25-30 years there's this
weird switch kids used to be furniture
or pets at best right i've got to make
sure we run this household and over the
last 25 30 years they've turned into the
epicenter of the household
and in the name of nurturing it well it
started out in the name of nurturing and
it's become in the name of propping up
my ego because i'm not happy at work i'm
not happy in my marriage i'm not happy
i'm disconnected from a church my
community
but if you find yourself waking up
thinking about little league baseball
plays you you probably got a problem if
you wake up thinking if you're an adult
an adult i'm gonna pitch this guy in
this weekend or okay if my daughter can
pull this trick off then she can get
this
we've gone way overboard man and we're
taking we've we've taken the fun and the
way that the parents treat the referees
tell you that it's bananas bananas i've
got friends who are
uh you know i worked in college i got
friends who are
trainers in college in universities
across the country telling me they've
got athletes who are 18 coming with
overuse joint injuries in their
shoulders knees and hips that they see
in elderly populations because these
kids at from age four
are getting personalized coaches and
specialized this you're only going to
play this you're playing year round not
doing other sports not just running and
playing and being a kid there's so much
psychology about the importance of just
let your kids play that's how they
figure stuff out it's how they stretch
your imagination they develop neural
connections all that stuff happens but
man when they feel like they're in a job
a kid cannot prop up and hold up i'm
getting fired about this i'm sorry they
they are do not have the strength to
hold up a mom or a dad's self-esteem
they do not have the strength to hold up
a home and the number of calls i get on
my show about
my a dad yelling at a kid for his
athletic performance or
all of that stuff breeds insanity stop
it stop it man let your kids play
and
your treasure's where your heart is
always
if you if you see that you're spending
so much on this
that it feels out of whack you know why
it feels that way because it's probably
out of whack right
it's probably out of control that's
right now our kids did cheerleading and
took cheerleading coaching my kids play
a little bit and my kids played rec
sports of all kinds i talked about
daniel playing hockey a minute ago
we spent money on other things around
that kind of a thing but we were under
no illusion that our child was going to
make a living cheerleading
and i'm under every illusion that if i
feel my blood pressure boiling over the
performance of a nine-year-old the
problem is not the nine-year-old the
problem is me
you know i it's uh one reason i dropped
my ut tickets
because i my blood pressure was boiling
over someone else was 18 years old
teenagers these are
hundred
teenagers
twenty thousand people threatening to
kill them that's right that's exactly
right over the use of a pig skin yeah
that's right
you know what i've lost my rabid mind
i'm with you and i'm i'm a football fan
but i had i was i spent a bazillion
dollars to go watch the game to be angry
right and i thought i'm just stupid or
the opposite to how my week fulfilled
because a group of
teenagers rallied up and won a game yeah
and if you're a tennessee fan that never
happened
not careful now now see what you did
yeah i see what you did there but yeah
we
and again so
playing sports is travel sports illegal
no is sports illegal no is you know is
spending money on violin lessons no
music is great music is good for the
brain development that's right i spend
money on that stuff for my kids and uh
you know that's fine but my
my wife took piano lessons and get this
you might be a hillbilly if
harmonica lesson there you go okay
so and we have the harmonica
so um we've we have used it a time or
two and some family jokes beyond belief
but uh giving her a hard time but she
could play neither
yeah
now
neither but she can deal with you and i
think
i think all the lessons she got growing
up are all came together for a purpose
god doesn't waste anything dave nothing
listed in god's economy nothing
nothing's wasted oh i'm touched
touched so i mean
that's the thing so i um let me yeah so
here's the thing if you are advancing
their
maturity
their ability to move into adulthood
fine but if you're if you're playing if
they're playing for you
which you can tell that with some of the
symptoms you gave laid out that's a
problem and one of the ways you can tell
that is the money will tell you because
the money gets out of control what
you're freaking spending
on the travel
on the uh lessons on the specialization
relative to your overall budget that's
right now again if you're if you got 20
million dollars and you want to spend a
hundred thousand dollars on your kid to
go do whatever that's fine like that's
fine but even that you got to look at it
and go this is a kid i just dropped 100k
on a sport they're never going to use or
on a music lesson they're really not
going to develop into a lot of parents
have stopped asking their kids what do
you want to do what do i do
one of the one of my worst parenting
moments that has become one of my
favorite
i would come home i was exhausted when i
was a dean of students i would plop on
the couch and i would watch the astros
game and i would try to instead of going
out and playing ball with my son i tried
to get him to watch it with me going out
and being with him i'd say hey let's
watch together and then one day he said
hey dad this is just six-year-old
innocence said hey do you love me as
much as the astros
and that's when we turned it off and
canceled it and then this is just a few
weeks ago
he came and said called a family meeting
i thought oh no what is happening he's
12. he's going to be saying hey mom dad
we need to talk but he said
i i don't know how y'all are going to
feel about this but i'm interested in
not playing sport x this year i would
love to try out for the school play
i've never been prouder of a 12 year old
which tells us we redeemed that and said
give him some language what are some
things you're interested in let's try
stuff let's expand it we're not gonna
no one's canning out scholarships for 12
year olds let's let's let these kids go
back to playing and let's let us do the
hard work of getting our identity in
other places man i wish it was not true
but they are giving out scholarships for
12 years they probably yeah
they shouldn't be that's right yeah it's
uh we're getting there but yeah the
thing is this guys
you know you need to
money in your life
where you're putting it and the ratios
and where you're putting it will speak
to you
as a symptom of an underlying problem
and where you feel anger is also a
symptom it's a of an underlying that's
right it's a signal yeah or great fear
or anxiety that's right also same thing
so the new book is own your past change
your future went on sale today deals
with a lot of these particular issues
that just happen to be right spot on for
this hour this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today the new book released for pre-sale
today it actually publishes in april but
you can get pre-sale on it today own
your past change your future a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness so make sure
you join in and
help us make that a bestseller as it
comes out of the gate john's first big
major book stephanie is with us in santa
rosa california says on my screen
stephanie you're debt free
congratulations
thank you it's so exciting it's good to
have you welcome how much have you paid
off
53 000
good for you and how long did this take
25 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
so i started at 75 and then went down to
40 and now back up to about 62 not
including like my side hustle i was
doing during the time cool what kind of
side hustle were you doing
i was delivering doordash ah how'd that
work you make some money i made a lot of
money yeah i did really well i did it
about two three nights a week since um
i started
in like about a year and a half ago yeah
what kind of money what's good money in
a month like in a month what would you
get
um probably about well i saved up about
five eight thousand dollars in a year
doing it so that's paid for my paid for
my car
what happened to your paycheck
they suddenly got cut in half for half
for a while
um well um a little thing called the
pandemic happened
what tell but tell us more just kidding
i know so i was living on unemployment
for a little while not working and then
just kind of wanted to get back out
there so i just took a job that i
that i liked and then another
opportunity came lapis came about and so
that's how i got my income back up again
good for you so what kind of debt was
your 53 000
um everything i had about 23 in student
loans i had a great car fleet
401k loan and season tickets credit
cards
everything you knocked it out wow good
for you i don't know
i had about nine payments i was trying
to manage at once every month
so how old are you
36. okay good for you so what does what
inspired you to get on this journey all
the job loss and everything was that
your wake-up call or something else
um no i actually started before i had
lost my job um i
started dating a guy and you know about
two months in he was telling me about
his journey with with you actually
and just encouraged me to get on board
too and and i did it
wow very cool
so is he still around
he is still around yes he's sitting next
to me right now oh he might be a keeper
okay
i know i think so good deal so you've
had a good cheerleader a good
accountability partner and encourager
oh 100 if i didn't have the
accountability like for myself
personally i needed that like because i
kind of would slap off you know every
once in a while and want to go to dinner
or want to do something so it was just
good having him in my corner like
keeping me going i like it well well
done good job i'm proud of you very cool
who who are your other cheerleaders
um my parents of course and then um a
really good friend i hope she's
listening her name is kat she kind of
got encouraged by us as well and her and
her husband
became debt free
with your journey using your steps also
and her sister is now um starting the
program so
just paying it forward for one friend at
a time i love it it's fantastic very
cool what was the hardest thing about
this journey you live in a very
expensive part of the country you were
grinding it you were doing doordash on
top of you what was the hardest part of
all of this
um honestly changing my lifestyle
because i mean i got into this mess by
mess by you know not caring and buying
what i wanted when i wanted it and
just having to not do that anymore and
budget myself i was just selling myself
spend 150 a week for gas groceries
everything
and it was just that was the hardest
part for me was 100 just the lifestyle
change
but way to go
and i have about three more months until
my emergency fund is done and then i can
start my 401k investing and all that
good stuff so it's great you are on your
way when is that guy sitting next to you
gonna quit waiting around
oh i i don't know
stephanie i'm trying i'm trying to help
you out here
i appreciate it john i appreciate it i
got it
tell him to call my show on another
thing we'll figure it out
i love it
well done hey we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth now
you can too number one best seller it's
our gift to you because we think you are
on your way to being a baby steps a
millionaire that's your next uh step in
your journey next part of your story as
you go along and i want to help you with
that we're also going to give you a copy
total money makeover for you to give
away to somebody and help them get
started and about eight nine million
people have now read that and um and
helped him with her get out of that plan
and head towards as you have head
towards not only debt freedom but now
becoming wealthy so
way to go stephanie
i like it thank you stephanie and santa
rosa california 53 000 paid off in 25
months making 75 to 40 to 62 plus the
doordash i love it i love it count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
one two
three i'm debt-free
[Music]
well done well done well done
oh man
that's cool
very cool and she showed her spreadsheet
uh which they popped up on youtube as we
were sitting here uh for you youtubers
you saw it too
season tickets i was gonna say it was
everything from victoria's secret to
49ers season tickets i love the way she
said it anything i wanted i just bought
everything right that's what most people
do that's right there you have it so
pretty interesting stuff very cool well
done stephanie very well done jeremiah
is with us in columbia south carolina hi
jeremiah welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you doing dave better than i
deserve what's up
uh so i just got into financial peace
university and i'm working on the baby
steps uh
i'm in step two right now so i actually
have instead of a thousand i currently
am sitting on about eight thousand
dollars
and the reason for that and the reason i
haven't paid it toward the debt yet
is i'm a single father um
i have primary custody of my daughter
and i'm looking at possibly having to go
back to court here soon which is going
to mean at a minimum a 5 000 retainer
for my lawyer
to uh continue my custody battle
um
i was just trying to get some advice on
how to deal with this now and how to
deal with it going forward if
more legal expenses come up wow i'm
sorry man
geez
that's hard
um
you treat it
like a
medical problem
financially speaking you treat it like a
medical problem
that as soon as there's healing you no
longer need to budget for it but as long
as you're in the medical fight
you need to budget for it it's an
ongoing
expense or potential expense expenses so
yeah you need to set aside some money
for something that you're you know you
fee it sounds like you feel like you're
90 sure this is coming again
yeah i'm not to see how tomorrow goes
i'm going to meet with my ex but
uh
there has they she is with her boyfriend
they have a kid and there's been some uh
investigations into abuse with them so
i gotta make sure i can do what i need
to do to
keep custody
yeah before you do anything having to do
with financial anything you take care of
the kids that's right great whether
there's potential abuse or potential
stuff you've got to protect your baby
yeah that's the first thing you do
outstanding and um you know if you have
to put your whole total money makeover
financial peace thing on hold
while you just fight this then do
and you'll get you know there'll be a
day that it does come to an end
right i don't know what day that is but
when it comes to an end then we don't
need a budget for it anymore or we can
step back into
a more enthusiastic mathematically
enthusiastic
hit on the stuff but you've got to take
care of kids in that situation first and
foremost agreed all right man i love
your heart jeremiah thank you for being
one of those dads that says not on my
watch i'm grateful for you man yeah
you're not doing this boyfriend that's
out of control nope nope not with my
kids
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
five two two five jordan's in houston
texas hi jordan how are you
doing well thanks for having me guys
great man what's up
all right man so here's my situation i'm
curious about where my business loan
falls into
my debt snowball and i'm kind of
struggling with some guilt that i've got
over
not being able to give 10 percent to my
church
and just how to manage those two things
together
how much is your business loan
ninety thousand who do you owe that to
um i owe it's a private loan so i
actually borrowed it from a family
member
okay
and so you signed a personal note right
correct yeah yeah so it's really a
personal loan
okay that you used for business
correct okay and um
what's your profit on your business look
like a year
um so last year so i bought a gym um a
week before the shutdown in march 2021
um great timing
yeah oh it was beautiful
and then
next week hey you're done and so
with it being a small gym to its
relationship based and so everybody with
all the change and the fear
that was the first thing to go
um
so anyway that said it you know we went
down to nothing for that year um
i think i lost money in 2021 and then
last year
i did about 40
um profit-wise and so we were just just
able to make buy
um at home and so i really don't have a
lot actually i don't have any extra at
the end you know we're following baby
steps or doing our best to and and
cutting back you know at home expenses
is there any other income coming into
the house all the things
yeah so my wife works as a teacher
and she makes what
she makes 52. okay so you you're making
40 off the business today and she's
making 52 off the business today
wow
ma'am
how's the growth coming putting the
income back what did what was the high
point on the gym what was the best it
ever did
um that was actually back in august um
i did we did 17 that month
um but that was the highest it's ever
done
what's that what in relation to small
relationship based gym i wouldn't expect
it to fall off
that next month like that what happened
in september
oh no so the next month it was just
about 1500 under that i think we were
right at 15 500. okay okay so wouldn't a
big drop off
no and we still haven't had a big drop
off currently we're just at a point
where
you know i'm making enough to pay for
expenses at home but nothing extra
and i'm making enough you know at the
gym to pay my staff to pay the bills
keep the lights on but nothing extra
like i don't have any extra
you know fluff in in the budget
whatsoever now back when the before you
owned the gym
what did it do
i was doing like
7 000 a month
and you did 17 000. so you've doubled it
correct
yes
and you paid how much for it
90.
and it wasn't even making money
um no it wasn't it was breaking even
okay
so you overpaid dramatically
correct
um
wow
okay so we're going to continue to fight
it and get the
continue to get the income up continue
to
work the business and i'll try to
increase your income out of the business
as much as possible
and what did you uh what'd you make at
your job before you took this jam on
um i made about 52. okay all right are
you next
what's that is the gym max is the gym
max
no it's not next okay no i can i can
probably double it again before we get
to the max point okay all right let's
keep working to double it then and
that's going to be the answer to working
yourself through this and the business
loan goes into the debt snowball which
also means it's probably the largest and
it's the big thing at the bottom how
much other debt have you got
zero no so this is it okay
yeah so yeah i think you'd fight this
tiger and
yeah if you could make 90 000 bucks
extra in um
in two years and pay it off in other
words increase your income by that much
by doubling which is what you're talking
about um then you're out of debt in two
years if it takes you longer three years
that's fine but you get this monkey off
your back this thing suddenly starts to
be a lot more fun to run agreed
agreed yes and
can i ask about the giving during this
process yeah sure yeah you know
i'm struggling with this concept of you
know i want to be able to give to the
church and i feel like i'm not trusting
enough to give you know because i know
the tides are supposed to come off the
top all that good stuff but at the same
time i don't know which bill i don't pay
if i give that 10 percent
well i i would challenge you that you're
not that close on your
budget it just feels like you are um
because you're down there fighting cash
flow every day and so you've got this
sense of
that i've i've just i've been doing
budgets for 30 years and
very seldom is somebody within 10
percent of being broke
it's just it's usually a lot worse or a
lot better
and so um this is about budgeting it is
about writing it down now what i would
challenge you on is the struggle part
okay number one uh i don't believe in
giving money to the church i believe in
giving my god
and the as an evangelical christian the
first 10
he teaches us to give is to the local
church but
i would change my phrasing on that
because it changes your heart when you
change your phrasing
uh you know the church really doesn't
need your money god really doesn't need
your money he wants to teach you to
become a giver
and he loves you
and so he's not wringing his hands
over you giving or not giving
it's just like if you have a kid and you
look at your kid and you say hey brush
your teeth you get to keep them that way
that's a loving father
right
and the kid's like yeah dad but i don't
really want to or dad it's not
convenient right now i'm a little too
busy i don't have the bandwidth um
you're like i know but when you don't
have any teeth someday you'll wish you
had brushed your teeth and this is a
loving father giving instruction to his
kid that he's crazy about do you hate
your kid or think less of your kid or
think your kid has got some kind of
issue if they don't brush their teeth no
he's just a kid and kids don't brush
their teeth sometimes adults sometimes
don't give
but your your heavenly father says son
the best way to live your life is to be
a giver
and jordan can i challenge you on
something
sure how much of this is a guilt about
giving and how much of this is guilt
over taking out that loan and overpaying
for a business
there's definitely some of that too i
think more so
it's it's
you know
not providing through you know a way
that i thought i was going to be able to
provide there you go
for my family not not necessarily about
overpaying for the business and
it's all of it but here's the deal you
cannot move forward if you're carrying
that bag of bricks around with you
and so at some point you have to make
the choice and it's hard and it's
something you practice but you got to
make the choice to say i did x
and that day is over and here is who i'm
going to become moving forward and i'm
going to start practicing those things
the giving part rallies around an
identity man it's like they would say it
rallies around who you are who you're
giving money to i think you just beat
yourself up so bad and then you think
man i can't let another dollar go out
this door that's not feeding my family
because of what i've done to us and you
got to put that crap down man yeah so
the way i talk to myself about it is i
go sometimes i do stupid things but i am
not stupid there you go
so i think we can put you buying this
business under the heading of stupid
stuff or at least what you paid for it
uh but you're not stupid i've been
talking to you for quite a few minutes
you're anything but stupid you're caring
you're loving i think you're probably
developing into a really strong good
businessman and i think you're going to
have a great thriving business it's
going to take you some time
and you're you'll never borrow money
again
and you'll never overpay for anything
again you've learned your lesson
and just like you know just like the
bible says borrowers slaves the lender
so get out of debt okay i don't want you
sitting around fretting and going i feel
awful i feel awful i feel awful but i do
want you to feel awful enough to get out
of debt that's right and the same thing
about giving i don't want you to be
guilted into it
or act like you're some kind of
christian boy scout or something doing
your duty but just go hey my heavenly
father who cares about me says the best
way for me to keep my teeth is brush
them
the best way for me to live is to be a
generous person i'm going to work
generosity into my plan even when it
doesn't feel like it fits i'm gonna
practice it
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money it is launch day as
we launch the pre-sale of john's brand
new book own your past
change your future you got to be sure
and check this out it's all about mental
health and wellness and
really about just relationships and
getting control of things creating
healing in the land john i'm really
excited about this thank you so much
this is 10 years in the making and lots
of personal stories and personal
experiences and
all the academic training and sitting
with family after family after family
all comes down to a
not so complicated approach to how we
need to get back on the wagon when it
comes to our mental health and
relationships yeah and it's uh you know
so here's the thing
every person listening right this second
has some relationship
something going on inside your head
that could get better that's right
including both of us sitting here that's
right absolutely and so it's a constant
process
it's a constant growing it's constantly
evolving you get better at handling your
money you get better with your marriage
you get better with your parenting you
get better at your relationships get
better at you you know managing the
stories in your brain and where that
takes you
yeah and
we joke about this there there will
never be a
i'm not depressed there's no depressed
free scream or no anxious free scream
right
because the moment you scream that you
go outside and pandemical hit someone
let you know that your mom passed away
so
this is more a set of principles for
how to get we've created a world for
ourselves that our bodies can't live in
and we're dragging these stories from
our childhood and from our from
yesterday with us everywhere how do we
set this stuff down and live a well life
emits this chaos that we've got in our
world
wow very cool i'm excited about it good
stuff good stuff open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money the new book is on sale
with all kinds of uh pre-sale
goodies thrown in including 30 days of
free counseling with the folks at better
health and they are pretty incredible
yeah better help really stepped up i'm i
could not have been more excited when
they stepped up and said we'll give a
free month's counseling to all the
pre-sale
folks here um it's how much they believe
in the book and we got a great
partnership but i'm you can finish this
book and and
quickly realize i probably should call
somebody and i love that we're able to
say all right here's the number and
there'll be a on the other end of that
line for you ryan is with us to start
off this hour in louisville kentucky hey
ryan welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and dr john thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
hello i need a little bit of advice um
before i ever knew who dave ramsey was i
had a credit card a discover card
and
the largest credit limit on the card was
was ever forty two hundred dollars and
so 2015 and 2016 make a long story short
worst year and a half of my life went
through a really bad divorce
uh lost my job so without a job for
about three quarters of a year and that
discover card payment that just kept
coming in i kept wanting to bury my head
in the sand and act like it wasn't there
and act like it wasn't there and so
eventually that 4200 credit limit
ballooned to about 10 000 and in 2017
was served with a judgment from discover
card for a total of
10 976.92
so started a payment plan with a
collection law firm
that started in june 2017 and went all
the way till
january of 2019 was the last payment i
made to them because in february
something happened in that year i can't
remember what it was but a payment
didn't get made or it got returned
and then i never heard from them again
like i never heard a phone from this
company i never got a bill in the mail i
never got anything until october 2020
they reached out sent me a letter
and were like hey you owe us money and
so i know you've touched on this topic
in the past but they just recently sent
me a letter here at the end of january
saying
that i could make a payment to them of
1932.77 so it would be
it would be good to go
the balance on the account right now is
48.31
so i just want to know your advice and
how you should handle that
okay
um
well obviously these things don't go
away they have a high rate of
resurrection
as my friend les parrott says
so uh yeah
it's it needs to be dealt with because
it's not going to go away until you deal
with it
and here's the thing you legitimately
owe some money
uh you possibly have paid already more
than you legitimately owed because it
sounds like they beefed this thing up to
no end to me
um and i think kind of sounds like you
feel that way as well right
yes yeah okay
so um do you know how much you've paid
them so far have you ever totaled it up
i paid them i paid them from from june
of 2017 up till january 2019 i paid them
six thousand one hundred and forty five
dollars okay
all right
so what i would do is um
jump on the phone with them and give
them these couple of numbers okay
um
how how far behind were you when you
first got contacted by them
uh so when i first got contacted by them
was when the sheriff said he showed up
at work with these papers yeah how far
behind were you then i mean it was it
was i guess after all the interesting
stuff had been yeah i'm saying how many
years
how many years um
that was probably 20
2015 was the last time so
that would be about a year and a half i
guess okay so um
here's the thing discover sold that
account
to a debt buyer
okay
debt buyers buy old bad debt to collect
on it
they collect on a very small percentage
of it
and based on the fact that it's very
hard difficult and almost impossible to
collect on even a little bit of it they
don't pay much for the old bad debt in
general it's about a nickel on the
dollar
okay
so they probably paid 200 for this debt
there's 4 200 on the books
all right so um you know one percent or
10 would be 400 bucks 5 would be 200
bucks so somewhere in that range is what
they paid for this debt
and uh so what i would go to them and
say is this
i met with my financial coach
and he says you guys bought this for
pennies on the dollar it was originally
4 200.
i have already paid you
over 6 000. 6192.42
or whatever the number is so i'm not
feeling like i owe you any more
however i will make you this offer i
will give you six hundred dollars
to completely close this account up and
be done with it
and begin a negotiation based on the
fact that a you know that they didn't
pay anything for this b you originally
owed 4 200 and have paid over 6 000 back
now
and c i'm tired of this crap and i want
you people to go away permanently so if
you send me in writing that you will
settle the account
by email or in the mail either one that
you will settle this account for 600
cash i will then wire that to you the
next day
i'm not going to pay you 1900 more
you've screwed me all you're going to
and just argue with them and you're
going to get an argument get ready and
go back and forth and if you settle it
for 800 is fine if you sell it for 1100
fine but get it settled for less than
1900 and use that negotiation process
and be prepared to argue and fight
through it and get it in writing or
don't give them any money and don't give
them electronic access to your checking
account
[Music]
so
[Music]
marriages across the country could all
use a date night right now an evening to
come together and focus on what matters
most connection and communication maybe
the challenges of the past year have
pulled you closer together or perhaps
you've drifted apart
with homeschooling or job loss or
financial stress no matter what your
marriage looks like right now we can
help you achieve better unity and
communication
at our special valentine's edition
of money and marriage
it streams live
this friday february the 11th
at 7 pm
right into your computer right into your
home rachel cruz and dr john deloney
will guide you and your spouse through
an unforgettable evening where you'll
realign the goals of your marriage learn
how healthy communication can improve
every area of your life and unify your
financial goals to put an end to the
money fights for good tickets for the
money and marriage livestream are
available they're only twenty dollars
they will not last long
and get that twenty dollars in your
february budget and head over to
ramseysolutions.com events
buy your tickets uh because the time for
stronger marriages right now one thing
is for sure with uh john and rachel
doing the event uh
will be a part of it you two caught up
way too much yeah she's fun man i'm
looking forward to this event and to
give people some tools give people a
break man i'm so sick of
greeting card companies and candy
companies telling me how i'm supposed to
love my wife and like this is the year
to do valentine's different right so get
some sweats get some food that you love
prop your feet up and let's have some
fun yeah so rachel and john will be
walking you through the money and
marriage event this coming
friday
the 11th of february at 7 00 pm go ahead
and get your tickets they're only 20 i
think ramsey plus subscribers is free
for that's right so you guys that are in
ramsey plus already you'll be able to
watch it for free and just make sure you
schedule this and get scheduled right
there on the couch and uh get the tv
going the whole thing and a whole new
way to go to a valentine's edition
money and marriage and gentlemen we will
make it worth your while trust me it's
not just going to be some
it's not a girly thing not a girly thing
it's going to be for everybody it'd be
fun yeah yeah it's it's it's a lot of
fun i mean you guys your humor and
communication style both of you is a lot
of fun so you guys will have a blast
check it out this friday night our
question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and with new promos they run
all the time you'll save even more use
the promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal all right today's question
comes from catherine in alabama
catherine writes i'm 25 newly married
and we are joining bank accounts i make
about 150 000 a year and he makes 50
000. i have over 180 000 in liquid
savings and could pay off all my
husband's debt today in one check
should i do this or should we work
through the baby steps so his behavior
changes
i don't want to bail him out
this marriage is brand new and already
off the track
man so catherine your husband is not a
bank
he's your husband
um there's two well man and then she
threw this last little line in here i
gotta think about it so yes i think you
pay the debt off and get your house
debt-free that is the baby steps but
there's something here
i don't know that
he's got some behavior issues
and he's not being responsible money
that's right that's right in her mind
right
and
whenever i see this i instantly feel
whether this is true or not and again
these are always one-sided because we're
not talking to people
you're no better than him or no
um more of an
extra contributor just because you make
more money y'all on the same team same
dream you're all head in the same place
he's got to get his behavior in check
but
you don't get to call the shots because
you make more money y'all are doing this
thing together and so i want you to sit
down and talk to him about that
yeah you're not his mom there you go
uh i i don't worry about his behavior um
you know sharon does not talk about me
that way right even if she doesn't like
my behavior which happens sometimes
right but um instead we're like two
adults and you know you sit down and go
you know i like your behavior yeah and
this is not okay and we're not gonna go
forward this way we're gonna go forward
another way
and um rather than you somehow
dangle the carrot of debt freedom until
he learns to
behave the way you want him to behave
that's right um this should have been a
conversation you'll have before you get
married yeah like
months ago right yeah your pre-marriage
counseling sucks
if you had if you had any yeah and uh so
yeah
because you guys got married and you
don't respect him
on this subject
and that's devastating to him
so uh don't take the position of his
mommy
um and don't take the position that he's
a bank that needs to be bailed out or
that you are better than him instead you
sit down and say um look you're my man
i'm your woman and we're gonna work on
this stuff together like two grown-ups
and uh here's how we're gonna handle
money going forward or we're gonna have
to go see a marriage counselor as our
first order of business of being married
uh because we have to get on the same
page about money because by the way
money problems and money fights are the
number one cause of divorce in north
america today
and catherine this isn't his debt
anymore you got married this is y'all's
debt yep y'all's debt
so as soon as you've had this
conversation
and there's a glimmer of light in his
eyes and goes okay cool let's get on a
budget together
let's uh start giving every dollar a
name you got 200 000 worth of income
in this household the two of you sit
down both of you have an equal vote
regardless of where the money comes from
we now have a budget where we spend
you know 20 000 bucks a month or 18 000
bucks a month whatever it is here on
paper on purpose and then we stick to
that
and we don't violate that contract
because that's like lying to my wife or
lying to my husband if i don't stick to
what i said i was going to do with them
that's called lying
and so we form a contract called a
budget where the two of us are both have
a vote and we're both in agreement about
where the money goes now if he continues
to be irresponsible in that setting you
don't have a money problem now you've
got a marriage and a irresponsible
husband problem
and then you've got to sit down with
somebody to help coach you guys through
this thing and that's really what should
have happened
in in the process but don't take the
position of
because you know later on you're going
to be dealing with a
50 year old man who says well i can't
buy something till i check with mama
[Laughter]
translation we all know that guy yeah i
know that guy i know him very very well
we all know that guy yeah
i gotta check in with mama and see if i
got any money well and this works the
other way right yeah you know i have to
ask my husband's permission if i'm
allowed to buy this dave will you let me
do that right it's like no you get a
vote too sharon
you know we both have a vote regardless
of i'm the only one creates any income
right but uh she created a lot of income
by allowing me to create income that's
exactly right and so um by you know not
having drama at home that helped create
income you know so uh
she gets a vote on you know this piece
of real estate we purchased this charity
event we're going to give or not give to
uh this thing you know this she gets a
vote in all of that
and uh regardless of where the income
comes from so 200 000 budget
lay it out for the month
where are we going to spend our money
and we are going to pinky swear in spit
shake this is a contract we're going to
stick to this now you have a responsible
adult working with a responsible adult
and that the day that you get that
glimmer which should be like by the end
of the week
um that you need to do this right now
tonight turn off the stupid television
yellowstone will wait
okay
1883 will wait tiger king await
just park it you can do this sit down
and uh
get this done and then write a check and
pay off his debt
and then moving forward let this be the
template for how you will always handle
both of you
challenges that come up in your marriage
you're not going to dangle this or
withhold that or well i'm just going to
do this or no we're going to sit down
and say hey in your weekly meeting that
you have or your nightly check-in with
each other that you have i'm struggling
with this thing whatever this thing
happens to be and by the way you're 25
right now you'll have a million things
over the next 50 60 years guarantee it
so practice now
having these hard conversations because
they only get harder this summer sharon
and i will be married 40 years oh
congrats man me and sheila are 20 this
summer 40 years congratulations and you
know what we have to align on more than
the budget today because we've been
doing the budget for 30 is calendar
if we can be in agreement on where our
time goes and our money goes we
generally are in agreement yeah
pretty simple
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage otis
and sandra are with us hey guys how are
you great good where do you all live
delhi louisiana okay close close to
monroe west monroe oh yeah i've been to
monroe right
worship in west monroe at church oh yeah
i spoke at the uh
the baptist church a white building you
know one time a thousand years ago
it may not even be still standing the
best eating on planet earth happens in
monroe louisiana there you go good now
you got my stomach telling me yeah well
welcome guys good to have you how much
debt have you paid off
eighty-five thousand three hundred and
eighty three dollars in 22 months way to
go and your range of income during that
time 87 000 to 96 000 back to 87. i love
it very good what do you guys do for a
living i am a medical coder i work from
home
and i work for uh lifeshare blood okay
what'd you do to get your income up 10
grand and then drop it back down lots of
overtime uh side jobs and when covet
happened actually nobody was going to
the emergency room so i didn't have any
accounts to code so my hours got cut
but i had a nursing license so i went
work to the nursing home so
and i worked there for about four or
five months and sometimes i would work
at home for eight hours and go work
eight ten hours at the nursing home so
just to help and he did side jobs that's
not only hard working at the time you
were doing that that was a little bit
scary for you it was it was yeah that's
that's fine high stress situation right
then yes it was what a brave woman
you're awesome yeah she is and they
needed you yeah yeah and what were you
doing otis i've been in the ministry for
about 30 years but i've i've taken a
another job now and doing something else
so
we've been working hard together to make
things work with us i got you cool tell
me about the 85 000 what kind of debt
everything credit cards yeah i thought
student loan would never go away
it won't unless you get rid of it that's
right car loans student loan credit
cards medical and all just kind of
normal normal very normal okay and you
just woke up and said uh we make 87 000
a year this has got to go away and it
sounds like you kind of started this in
the middle of the coven mess we did
right before we called it right before
right before so he used to listen to you
on the radio for years
and come home and he'd tell me stuff i'm
like well you know that's not gonna work
for us yeah so
read your first book though financial
piece and still didn't buy into it so um
then when we started was making that
kind of money and it was just us two and
so i you know was looking at everything
and i was like why we have so much money
but we still have all this debt
so i saw a friend mentioned you on
facebook so i thought let me let me
check this out so i started watching
your show
i knew it would work all along
you keep that one to yourself
bringing that up right now is not a good
time
[Laughter]
i've always had good radio stations in
monroe so i'm not surprised that i got
that i got through to otis on the radio
and then
and then uh sandra looks me up on
youtube that's right that's right uh us
up i guess the whole gang here yeah so
very cool all right so how long you two
been married it will be 35 years on
valentine's day oh all right just coming
up then that's right monday all right
very cool what's what happened several
years ago that got you on this journey
it was like i said just just yeah just
relax just seeing that debt just being
there knowing it wasn't going away we
just knew we had to do something
different all right so you say we're
going for it and then all of a sudden
covet hits did you all have a freak out
moment or what can't you go with maybe a
little bit and then about three or four
months after that we took fpu so through
zoom oh wow and uh so we did that with a
couple and that just kind of helped
because all we had left then was the car
and the student loan
and so
and so we really pushed forward and uh
we got our student loans paid last on
christmas day oh that was our christmas
present to each other
how long have you had sallie mae around
oh
too long
it goes back many years
decades yes decades yeah wow yes well
good for you you're free amen right
right first time in 35 years yeah
wow how's it feel great amazing
unburdened yeah that's right amen that's
right amen well congratulations you guys
all right very very proud of y'all yeah
we have this past year has been really a
struggle for us so we paid off our debt
and it helped us to realize that we our
marriage needed work
so uh just pulled us together and saw
that so that's when he decided to leave
ministry we decided to focus on us
we've been doing counseling and better
than we've ever been so we're not only
debt free we're free from our past
i love that yeah healing promotes
healing promotes healing that's exactly
right yeah it's hard to work on one area
and get everything straightened out
without working on the others
it just always ends up that way that is
so powerful good for you all right what
a brave big decision
there's two brave people in front of me
yeah
wow lots of big decisions yes career
changes and you know different kinds of
commitment changes and if we had not
been debt free it wouldn't have been
possible for us to focus on that so
that's that's made a huge difference
yeah
after sharon and i went broke we uh we
were too worried about eating and
feeding kids to even notice what we'd
done to each other and it was about
three years later that we decided to try
to kill each other you know and we end
up you know we end up with a marriage
counselor and i'm going i'm gonna kill
this one
you're an idiot i was i was an idiot
four years ago
that's not changed i was it was but it
was the same kind of thing we healed
enough in that area to where it allowed
us to go oh crud this other area is
broken right right and uh same exact
process so
very cool you guys very proud of you
very well done very well done we've got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure
and a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away and get somebody else's
journey going you've been through
financial peace university you've
checked out the radio the podcast the
youtube you've been with us everywhere
thank you thank you for hanging out with
us we're honored and then coming to
nashville to do this live that's right
very cool and i don't want folks to miss
before you do this i want folks to miss
you're an inspiration because you paid
off all your debts and it's incredible
but i don't want to miss the other parts
of your journey here it takes a brave
person
a brave couple to say we've been married
for 35 years it's time for us to
recommit reconnect to do this thing and
we're going to need some professional
that's hard yes and there's lots and
lots and i say lots i mean millions of
marriages in that same spot i'm proud of
you guys and thank you for the example
you just set for the whole country it's
never too late to say let's read let's
redo this thing that's right good for
you yeah all right
proud of you turns out us old dogs can
learn new
if you're brave you can't that's right
but you got to be brave that's right
good for you guys it requires a level of
courage so very well done you guys proud
of you good stuff all right otis and
sandra monroe louisiana 85
dollars paid off in 22 months making 87
to 96. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Applause]
yeah
i love it
that is so powerful
so powerful personal finance is eighty
percent behavior it's only 20
head knowledge the problem with your
money is not a math problem
the problem with your money is the
person in your mirror
and the relationships that person
engages in over the last 30 years how
much of that 80 percent this behavior
is
communication that first conversation
it's got to be a big chunk of the
ability to play well with others yeah
you know to tell your
crazy cousin no yeah to set a boundary
right no i'm not giving you any more
money you're a drug addict i'm not
giving you any more money to tell your
spouse we got to get on the same page
we got to heal this thing to look at
yourself in the mirror forgive yourself
for being an idiot yep because i got a
phd in dumb i know what stupid looks
like i've looked at him in the mirror
i know this guy but also no i don't do
the same stupid thing twice so i look
for new stupid things to do but i don't
do the same one twice i'm gonna learn
i'm gonna get better i'm gonna evolve
i'm gonna heal in every one of these
areas and i don't have to repeat i don't
have to cycle
on any of these areas of my life and you
don't and you guys out there don't
but this idea that somehow i can
simply go make more money and it'll be
okay
nope wherever you go
there you end up my friend you will
follow you everywhere yeah
the old the old story of the guy on the
road and he asked the old man
um you know how are the people in that
town back there and he goes how did you
find them in the last town
that's how you'll find them in this
that's right how did you like that last
job oh the leaders were jerks i bet you
they are at the next place yep
there you go i bet you there's a good
chance of that you seem to attract those
kind of people
but then you look at otis and sandra and
they said no more we're going to change
it we're going to break the science
changing change our family tree good
stuff this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 3 21 my son
do not let wisdom and understanding out
of your sight preserve sound judgment
and discretion
mark twain said good judgment comes from
experience and a lot of that comes from
bad judgment
kind of what we were just talking about
what a great quote
kind of what we were just talking about
well it's tax season
i don't know anybody who loves that
unless you're an accountant
truth is most of us dread taxes
it's a pain it's confusing filing taxes
is bad and tax software can all time
oftentimes make it even worse and then
they try to sell you debt on top of that
but filing your taxes doesn't have to be
horrible we created ramsey smart tax to
give you software that you can actually
trust
smart tax has steps that are simple
they're clear so you know
you've done your taxes right no more
headaches no more second guessing and
we'll never tack on surprise fees
or try to sell you
scummy company sell your info to scummy
companies or something like that when
you sign up for ramsey plus it's even
easier
you even file your taxes with ramsey
smart tax free as a part of being in
ramsey plus so don't get taken advantage
of by your tax software ever again start
your free trial of ramsay plus and file
your taxes for free at ramseyplus.com
that's ramsayplus.com
that's a pretty good and clean and
simple way to do that uh corrine is with
us in new york hi corinne how are you
hi i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up in your world
so
both my husband and i uh work full time
so our agi combined is about 94 000 but
he also sells computers part-time
he sold
about 250 000 computers just this year
alone
but we're not seeing any profit we're
only seeing loss on our taxes with
business expenses and credit cards
you know i'd love to help them but with
12 hours a day working and traveling to
and from work like you know i don't have
time to help him with bookkeeping and
things like that
so what would be your suggestion should
i leave my job and help him and you know
stay with the kids or should we hire
someone you should hire someone hire
someone over here you didn't tell me you
hate your job you just said your husband
was struggling
right
i don't hate my job i just feel like by
the way you're making money and he's not
yeah
profit
what's the loss here is it the cost of
the computers
how are you selling 250k and walking
away losing money
right
most of the money is filtering back into
the business so he's buying more
computers
and using the credit cards to pay for
more computers and then putting more
money back on the credit card so it's
just a
vicious cycle
no it's horrible business yeah practice
absolutely horrendous
um it sounds like this guy knows how to
sell computers but is horrible running a
business
right money management is well managed
managing the business is
part of money management is part of
accounting
you have to be able to do that at a
certain level to operate a business
and you can learn it it's a learned
skill it's very possible
but um what he needs to do is jump
online
at ramseysolutions.com click on elp for
taxes and find a a cpa in your area that
we trust that we endorse to help you set
up a set of books and and the cpa can
actually
teach him how to do the bookkeeping
and you can get some simple software
there's all kinds of software out there
to get started in business uh that's not
super complicated but this guy does not
know how to run a business he just knows
how to sell computers
and he's gonna have to learn that or
he's gonna shut this down
because let me tell you what's gonna
happen all of a sudden the sales are
going to stop and he you know he's going
to be like musical chairs the chairs are
going to be gone he's going to be
standing there holding the credit card
debt and it's over
that's true that's what's going to
happen here i've watched it happen tens
of thousands of times over the years of
coaching small business people and
here's the problem with a great he's a
great salesman isn't he
yes very good yeah i'm a great salesman
too and the thing that i tried to do
when i was at his stage is i tried to
outs out earn my stupidity
you can't make enough to be stupid
but a salesman think you can
i know i am one okay and he really the
truth is if you tell him that he'll
start laughing you go honey we can't out
earn your stupidity you've got to get
you're going to have to get up under
this business and start setting up basic
operational things basic accounting
things
shipping
you know some of the other stuff he's
just he's just running around
hanging on by a thread in every area
except sales which he's excelled at
so would it be a good idea to help him
with that
if you can without quitting your job
if you can without quitting your job but
he doesn't
you know he could put a bookkeeper on
his payroll and they'll pay for
themselves in about 30 seconds
is he exhausted corrine or is he like
this
shuffle it seems like doing this much a
lot he's doing a lot but he works full
time and then part time every other time
he's doing this he doesn't sleep oh this
is on the side yes
what does he make of his full-time job
about 49. what do you make at your
full-time job
57 okay so you have hundred thousand
dollar income and then he's got a side
gig that's basically churning 250k
yes in and out
yes yeah you need a bookkeeper or an ops
person operational person a bookkeeper
business manager office manager that can
do bookkeeping type of a thing that can
help him with administrative things
including some basic accounting
functions
um and uh
you know it can be a guy can be a gal
and a hundred years ago we called him
girl friday you ever heard that phrase
but it's somebody that comes in and
takes a it's your business mom
you know that comes in and help that's
your one of your first hires when you
get going in a business it could be a
business dad i don't care i'm not it's
not a sexual sex thing it's a man or
woman doesn't matter to me but
somebody's got to come in and bring the
skill sets that he does not have or this
thing's going to or he ought to just
stop doing it
right
and let me tell you this it's not an
option for him he loves it is an option
it is an option don't back yourself into
a corner and don't let yourself be
backed into one either that's true
that's always one let me tell you
the relief and peace i felt when i had a
supervisor a job or two ago that came to
me and said you were really good at this
i'm gonna teach you and get you some
help on this part and i fought it it was
it was against my ego and i pressed back
a little bit and then
oh man i was able to breathe and so i
would approach this like dave said
talk to him about what he's really good
at and then say let's make this part
right because we miss you at home i miss
you
this thing is not working you're not
good at this thing somebody may need to
raise prices you may need to change
shipping
you you may need to uh whatever you
definitely got to cut up the credit
cards and stop cycling
the thing and start running it on a cash
basis for sure
uh but cash basis accounting is i buy
stuff when i have
money hey that's that and that's cash
basis accounting and that's how all
small
businesses should start some people
start them on credit cards 38 of small
businesses in america right now are
running credit card debt as an
operational thing wow and that is
suicide it's terrible you know it's
terrifying of what it'll do to you so
yeah you've got to get him out of that
so um yeah get him with one of our tax
elps and or find somebody that you can
hire to bring in or or get the virtual
assistant the people with belay can help
you with that that might be an answer
get with the entree leadership team here
um and i'll send you a copy of the book
entree leadership to help you guys get
started on this because it sounds like
he's got the beginnings of something
that ought to work
uh it may just be simply he hadn't got
his margins straight he needs to raise
prices it may be that he's shuffling
this so much he can't tell what's going
on whether he's really making money or
not he may actually be making money and
then just dumping it all back in
um because he's not he's not managing
cash
he's managing um a shell game hiding the
p well here's a here's another thing she
didn't mention so i'm just putting this
out there he may not be making that much
money
and i would want to see all the numbers
out on table and this may help from a
trust perspective for your marriage just
to say i want to see the books on this
thing i want to see how this thing is
running
that's a lot of income to be churning to
walk away and still the boat's still
sinking
um
something doesn't feel right to me about
this whole thing
yeah it's all it is a lot of uh to have
zero profit have zero but you can you
could call it no profit by just dumping
it all back in that's right yeah and
just by churning it yeah you know and
trying to trying to parlay it up partly
up from nothing to 250. yeah so
somebody's moved the p that far if
you're not bringing anything home to
support your family it's a real
expensive hobby kind of miss the point
that's right kind of missed the point
this
is the ramsey show we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you